le lièvre et la tortue conte créole
réunionnais traduction et adaptation
d'yvette duchemann aux éditions sourya
qu'on perd lièvre converter tu se
promènent et discutent dans un grand
jardin qu'on perd tortue est perplexe il
dit à son camarade je ne comprends pas
tous les joueurs je sors je vais
chercher du travail ici sur la terre
mais je n'en trouve pas il n'y a plus
rien n'est fait il donc faire son ami le
liège lui répond aussitôt
moi j'ai une idée c'est simple il faut
aller voir le bon dieu et chercher du
travail là haut dans le ciel vers totu
acquiesce immédiatement allons la mer
monte
mais comment vas tu faire toi qu ils
l'ont si lent tellement long du le
lièvre en liant les deux compères se
mettent d'accord et décident de voyager
le lendemain le lendemain matin compères
tortue se prépare de très bonne heure
quand il est prêt il se glisse dans la
bertel de son camarade yeves qui ne le
voient pas ce dernier s'est réveillé de
bonne heure il endossa bertel et montent
jusqu'au ciel dès qu'ils arrivent au
ciel ils bossent à mai at elle par des
compères liège n'en croit pas ses yeux
quelle surprise qui va t'il devant lui
mais comment tu fais pour arriver ici
devant moi toi qui lancent ils ont
tellement lent oui oui bien sûr je mange
lentement mais je mange depuis hier soir
je n'ai pas dormi moi répond qu'on perd
tortue encore ébahie qu'on paie aliev
propose à son ami de commencer à
travailler et tous les deux travaillent
pendant toute la journée le soir venu
qu'on paie alliait se glisse à nouveau
dans la baie at-elle de son compagnon
pour redescendre sur la terre qu'on paie
aliev se frotte les yeux mais ce n'est
pas possible tu arrives sur la terre
avant mais ce n'est pas possible mais
comment fais tu toi qu'ils ont si dans
tellement lent berton tu qui a plus
d'une parole dans son simple répond
tranquillement mais c'est simple je
descends faisant des quenottes deux mois
mon ces points ainsi tous les jours
qu'on perd tortue monte et descend dans
la berthe est deux compères lièvre
cependant la mac robert-lieb voit son
ami entrée
presti ce mandant saab airtel et ne dit
rien et l'emmène au travail le soir venu
compères liev annonce à compeyre tortue
da londres tu sais je voulais te dire je
vais brûler ma b attelle mais comment ça
mais pourquoi mais attend moins d'être
aubin mais enfin quel mousse te pique
mais je ne comprends pas dit qu'on perd
tortue complètement à basseau dit qu'on
perd liev à déterminer il prend des
feuilles sèches
quelques branches il en fait un feu il y
jette sa mère tél non je t'en prie ne
fait pas ça tu as besoin de cette bête l
atome est d'être en bas qu'on perd trop
tu cries essaie en vain d'enlever la
bertel du feu il pleure et les
désespérés ils regardent la bertel qui
se consume lentement très lentement mais
du peur
pourquoi pleures tu ainsi que
t'arrive-t-il compères tortue demande
qu'on perlière n'en sais rien c'est
cette fumée elle me brûle les yeux
tiko pertes obtus pendant que la perte
elle se consume totalement qu'on perd
lièvre quant à lui se prépare pour
redescendre sur la terre qu'on perd tant
qu ne le suis pas vas-y ne m'attend pas
je descends dans un moment qu'on paie un
lièvre des sangsues à la terre resté
seul compères temps tu réfléchis il
connaît les arbres il grimpe un mao et
rapidement très rapidement il
confectionne une corde avec l'écorcé de
l'arbre
une fois celle ci terminée il attache à
un tronc d'arbre
il commence à redescendre sur la terre
malheureusement l'accord d'être aux
côtes et qu'on perde ton tu sud dans
l'arrière-cour deux compères lièvre tant
bien que mal qu'on perd tortue se remet
de son choc
il entend compères liège qui crie mais
qui me nargue humaine qui lancent des
cailloux sur ma maison c'est moi copé à
lierse et moi je suis tombé répond qu'on
perd tortue compères liesse au de chez
lui et vient à la rencontre deux
compères temps tu mets que t'arrive-t-il
compères tortue tout penaud lui répond
tu savais bien que je montais que je
descendais chaque joie dans ta bertel
comment je vais faire maintenant je suis
long silence tellement lent
comment vais-je faire maintenant que tu
l'a brûlée j'ai failli me tue avec cette
cottereau quoi tu en perds liev le
regarde et lui dit gravement
c'est vrai que tu es mon ami cependant
tu dois comprendre que dans la vie il
faut prendre son courage à deux mains
au lieu de compter sur les autres je te
laisse y réfléchir